before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
well I suppose if anything was going to
get me to drop an extra video this week
it would be fashion
thank you
that was a really dumb lead-in I'm not a
super fashionable person and I don't
really care about fashion as is
evidenced by the fact that I'm sitting
here on a damn t-shirt anyway so there's
been a number of things that have been
sort of trickling out about Doctor Who
that I haven't really talked about and I
think it was starting to become
conspicuous by my lack of discussing it
so you get an extra video this week
so there were well there was the initial
thing that a lot of people wanted me to
talk about or assumed I had an opinion
on which was the casting of jinx monsoon
in the upcoming Doctor Who series which
will feature shurigatwa as the 15th
doctor and I didn't really have much of
an opinion on that I'll get to why in a
second ultimately then
two more things happen one directly
related to that and one not necessarily
so far as we know but all doctor who
connected then maybe go okay like I
I should I should cover these and if I'm
going to do those I'll just round up all
the stuff I haven't talked about yet and
so that was the costume reveal a new
additional costume reveals for the
doctor and the companion
looking all very 60s and decked out with
a very different look especially for the
doctor and then the actual costume
reveal for the still at present
unidentified character that Jinx Monsoon
is playing so let me come back to the
first thing the fact that I didn't
really have an opinion on Jinx monsoon's
casting and the reason I don't really
have an opinion on that is because
I don't
know them
I I had to go back and forth on the on
the pronoun thing because I know that as
a drag performer they will be referred
to as she but outside of drag they are
non-binary and use they them pronouns
but at the same time I look at this
casting and this image and I'm like wait
are you performing as drag and I don't
know I'm going with they them it makes
the most sense to me
so yeah I don't know them I don't know
the work I stopped watching drag race
after the fourth season I'd gotten
whatever enjoyment I was going to get
out of the concept and all the kinds of
things it was doing I was ready to move
on I did I haven't come back I don't
want to please don't encourage me and
say oh but watch this season it's pretty
good like I don't want to I I don't want
to watch drag race so there's that I
technically I have seen some of their
work in that they voiced a character in
Steven Universe
the problem is I don't remember Emerald
the character they voiced that character
appeared in one episode there were over
150 episodes of this thing
I don't remember them so sorry and I
don't really have much opinion to give
when I have no basis by which to judge
how they're going to perform this this
is part of why I have not had as much to
say about the any of the casting so far
be it the casting for the doctor the
casting for the companion like I don't
know the work of these people so when
people like do you think they'll do a
good job I'm like I don't know
we'll find out and it's kind of the same
thing I think there was a bigger
assumption here that I would have an
opinion because Jinx Monsoon is a drag
performer is non-binary and there's I
guess a presumption that that inherently
makes me
either know more about them or be more
aware of them or to care more like look
I'm glad that the casting is you know
bringing in
you know unusual choices I'm down with
that as a general principle cool but I
have no particular investment in Jinx
and that's not me saying I don't think
they'll do a good job I have no idea I
have no idea
I do have a little bit of opinion on the
costume though but we'll come back to
that let's talk about the 60s outfit for
the doctor and the companion I mean now
the companion it's an alternate look
cool
that's fine the doctor feels more
notable for a couple of reasons the
first is that
while there have been variants on
different outfits for the doctors in the
modern era obviously David Tennant had
the pinstripe suit but also the blue
suit and the 11th doctor you know went
from you know went with tweed a longer
coat he had the purple look the 12th
doctor you know started out you know
very tightly buttoned up in his his look
loosened over time but he always had he
always had you know the long coat I mean
he had a couple different ones but the
thing is there was usually a through
line of consistency somewhere in there
Lieutenant is just well it's a suit
here's one suit here's another suit
different suits with um Matt Smith it
was the same general makeup you know
just changing up what the jacket was of
the material or the color scheme but
like always a jacket always a bow tie
and in the case of Capaldi always
layering it the same way always having
that jacket on the outside sometimes we
had a hoodie sometimes we don't but then
there's something underneath that so
like it's still a general assembly of
the look still pretty similar
this is really different
from the other look that we've seen from
and more to the point
it's within the same series
because generally more severe variants
like I'd say the one who varied the most
might have been Capaldi or maybe
arguably Smith you know given uh going
from the more professorial Look to You
know the whole purple thing but like
that was across multiple series and same
with Capaldi the major shifts in terms
of how tightly buttoned up he was in his
first series to how loose his look was
in later ones that was over multiple
Series this is stuff from the same
Series so that's interesting that
they're varying up his look that much
within the same series because this is
not the same feel
like at all in terms of the construction
of the look the color scheme like oh
it's like this is very different
then there's also the hair and I do
wonder about that
I I I saw it suggested then this would
be an interesting thing that like
is it possible they got trapped in the
60s for a while kind of like what
happened to Martha and David Tennant uh
in blank where they were stuck in a
decade for a little while and she had to
get a job it makes me wonder that
because like
his hair was really closely cropped in
the earlier reveal this look is this is
something else altogether so I mean I
suppose logistically there's three
possible explanations there is It's A
Wig and as a practical matter it
probably is but that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's a wig in Universe
um that would be a an interesting choice
for the doctor to start messing around
with wigs
I think you could work with that but I
don't know so there's that there is the
possibility that time enough time has
passed that it's just started to grow
out if it does would he keep it for
episodes after that that'd be
interesting I mean not like massively oh
this changes everything but like oh
variable look that kind of sticks that'd
be that'd be kind of neat
um then another possibility
can he just will his hair a little bit
bigger a little bit longer
I don't know
I mean I suppose with everything else
the doctor can do why not
what the heck
but it it just added one more thing to
make this look so distinctly unlike
because like it just it doesn't even
match the silhouette even just of his
head
for the look that we've seen before
which again
that's kind of interesting I'm kind of
curious to get full context on that and
again it is a sharp look it I will say
that it is consistent with the early
look as far as that goes this is a
Dapper well to put well put together
sharp look so we do have a consistency
of strong fashion sense for this doctor
just you know
actually now that I think about it if he
has that strong fashion sense it would
make more sense for him to shake it up
maybe more than other doctors would
yeah
yeah sure because like you get somebody
like Jody Whitaker who literally threw
her out her outfit together out of stuff
in a charity shop it kind of makes sense
that she's not so fashion conscious as
to really ever change her look over the
three series that she had other than
occasionally wearing the red shirt
instead of the blue one but um if he's
gonna look this sharp and put together
in fashion forward like yeah he would
have multiple looks
okay cool
Jinx monsoon's look
makes me nervous and again keep in mind
this has nothing really to do with them
as a performer because I don't know them
that having been said
there's a very high camp look to this
part of me wants to go we don't know if
that's necessarily the makeup and the
hair that they're going with but like
given their nature as a drag performer
and you know why would you do a
professionally shot reveal of a costume
but have not the correct hair and makeup
it'd be a very strange choice if they
did that
so I'm going to assume that it is
accurate to how that they how they will
look now they it has now been confirmed
that they are playing a villain which is
a very villain look
and it's a very Camp villain look and
again this is not about them
this is about the fact that the camp
aspects of the Davis run especially in
series one
were some of the stuff that I liked the
least when I first saw it and I've never
fully come around on the more camper
instincts that he has while I'm not
going to say are ill-fitting to Doctor
Who Doctor Who has a lengthy history of
varying degrees of Camp intentional or
not but the thing is
Davies RTD and his his love of that
aspect it's it's it's not mine I mean
this is something that happens with
anything that runs this long the things
that I love about Doctor Who may not
necessarily be the things that other
audience members or indeed uh
showrunners love about Doctor Who and
they may choose to bring forward certain
aspects that aren't the things that I'd
like to see emphasized and for me Camp
kind of kind of falls into that now I've
softened a little bit on it uh over time
versus how I first felt when I would see
uh you know stuff like the burping trash
can from Rose or even an episode like
Voyage of the Damned and villains like
Max Capricorn like I I don't love them I
will never love them I tolerate them at
this point I'm like it it's there it is
what it is
but it's not something I was ever going
to request more of
and seeing a villain presented
looking like this
that
I'm not going to say it's impossible for
this to be a more seriously toned
villain but it would be a very odd
choice to have a more seriously toned
villain present like this especially
with sort of the key the like the um
piano Motif which has also led to some
speculation that this might be a musical
villain if not a lead-in for a musical
episode and I won't spend too much time
speculating on that but I will say I'm
not I'm personally not super enthused by
the notion of a musical episode of
Doctor Who I know musical episodes were
a you know huge thing for a little while
like I don't know a decade back or so
more than that now because I'm old but
and while some of them were good some of
them were great even it's not a thing
that I need more of necessarily and
again it's something I will say that if
you're going to do a musical episode you
probably would do well with a more Camp
villain so like if if
this is a villain for a musical episode
or at the very least the villain
themself is going to be bursting into
song then leaning into the camper
aspects for that character or that story
is
probably a good idea but again this just
indicates potentially a lean into
aspects of Doctor Who that aren't
generally what I'm here for
and if it's a one-off and just like one
crazy episode amongst you know amongst
the series that is doing a bunch of
other stuff
it probably won't bug me too much uh
even if I don't like it
but if it's an indicator of the tone of
the entire thing that would be a point
of concern now given that it's not
confirmed that Jinx masoon is playing a
recurring villain I don't really have a
ton of basis on which to get too worried
Beyond whatever specific episode this is
going to appear in so
I I look at this and again to reiterate
has nothing to do with Jinx themselves
because I don't know their work but I
look at this look this outfit this make
up this hair and I go oh
it just it just brings to mind
the the kinds of instincts that RTD
sometimes had with Doctor Who that
just don't clickfully for me I know a
lot of other people are really excited
either because they're more familiar
with jinx's work or because they do
enjoy the camper aspects of Doctor Who
and for those people I'm happy for you
because if this stuff's going to be done
somebody should love it somebody should
be excited for it and honestly I hope
most people are
it's hard for me to be though and until
I actually see it in execution now it's
not impossible that I will end up
enjoying whatever specific character or
story this ends up all playing out in
however given what it appears to be
leaning into
it's going to make it a little bit
tougher for that to be something that's
really going to land right with me it
might like one of my favorite things and
I've said this repeatedly and I'll keep
saying one of my favorite things is to
watch something that I don't think is
going to work for me and having it work
and I go oh that surprised me in the
best way because I didn't think I was
even gonna like it and I loved it and
sometimes that happens it's rare but
when it does it's a super special thing
and I'll always hope for it but I won't
expect it because if I expect it that
I'll be disappointed in addition to not
enjoying a thing and I don't need to add
that on to uh you know my feelings for
an episode of a show that I love and
want to continue to love so those are
sort of my general thoughts and feelings
on some of the stuff that has gone on
lately
hold up breaking news yeah I gotta jump
in here because
two days before this video is scheduled
to go live more news broke they really
do time the release of these things just
to mess with me I am convinced at this
point so
Murray gold the composer for a Doctor
Who series 1 through 10 plus all the
specials in between all those is
returning to score Doctor Who he's
replacing segun akanola who did the
compositions for the Jody Whitaker and
Chris chibnell era and this
that I'm I'm actually right now
genuinely legitimately
getting very nervous as more and more of
this pulls together
I said when RTD was first announced to
be returning that my faith in this being
something worth watching was an inherent
trust that he was going to do something
new with it
and not just repeat or attempt to
recapture what it was he did in the
mid-2000s that he was going to come in
with fresh ideas he's grown he's changed
as a Creator he's I think he's gotten
better in a lot of ways he's become a
more nuanced more intricate more
thoughtful writer uh in quite a few
areas and I was really interested to see
that applied
and I kind of was a little bit more
forgiving of the return to David Tennant
that I would have been otherwise partly
for that same reason like oh what
different thing is he going to do with
tenant
but the more things fall into place
the more I'm getting legitimately scared
that this is going to be more a
recapturing of what was done before
unless a
reinvention or a new take or uh a new
way of doing it from a Creator who had
done it before
because at this point
let's set tenet aside because it is just
the specials and then after that we have
shurigato so let's focus on that
we have a returning showrunner
working with multiple returning
producers
and now a returning composer
and then there's what I talked about
with Jinx Monsoon which has the
potential to indicate a return of a
specific type of flavor that he brought
to this property before that is one I
don't really want to see return not
heavily
I have not given up hope I'm not I'm not
there I'm trying to be more optimistic
than that but the more things fall into
place
the harder it is for me to have a ton of
faith
in the idea that this isn't going to be
a repeat now is it is it impossible for
it to be something new and exciting and
just have all these existing pieces in
in place no it's not impossible of
course not
but the more things that line up to how
he was doing it before the less
just reasonable an expectation that he's
not going to do the same thing feels and
again it's possible and I'm going to
hold on to that hope but that's the
thing it's now a hope it was faith I had
Faith he wasn't going to just try and
recapture and redo the same thing I
don't have faith anymore I have hope
but that's a lot more fragile that's not
based on as much because my faith was
getting undercut with each new
announcement that just lined up with
stuff that he did before and Murray gold
very much falls into that and whether or
not you liked the music from Series 13
uh you know 11 12 13 whether you liked
that at all or liked it better or worse
I don't think this is A Great Notion
like I enjoy Murray Gold's soundtracks
actually I really hope that now that
he's back they will sort out whatever
freaking licensing issue he was holding
up that was keeping us from getting an
official release of the soundtrack to
series 10.
at the very least I better get that out
of this deal because if that doesn't
happen what the FM
but I was ready to be done with him I
didn't think the music for the chiminal
era was amazing but it was also doing
something very different it was more
ambient music it was more for atmosphere
and it was way less bombast which I
think is a valid way to score well not
just Doctor Who score anything
and again I like marigolds up I love a
lot of Murray gold stuff
but
bringing him in again
doesn't give me a lot of confidence
right now
that it's going to be new and fresh
honestly the only repeat thing I wanted
was RTD himself
and I wasn't nervous at the time that he
was working with older producers I
figured that was just a comfort thing
but
I'll tell you what's the thing that
might diminish my hope to a very dull
flicker
right now the only uh writer that we
have confirmed is RTD himself I did a
video about the rumor that Moffett might
come back I did a video there I honestly
don't think that's going to happen but
that was more talking about the
possibility of if he did
so I'm not going to put a lot of credit
into that at this point but once we get
additional writers announced
if it's all writers who not only wrote
for Doctor Who before but wrote for
Doctor Who under RTD before
I'm gonna have almost no hope left that
this is going to be something new
and not just a recapturing of what it
was before
because that's that's about the last
piece to be put in I was willing to roll
with tenant Donna coming back as a
send-off just for the specials and and
with the hope that it would go in a New
Direction after that
but now so many of the things that are
being put in place
they
it's old stuff
now it's possible
that the performers the doctor and the
companion and you know whatever else
ends up going on it's possible that
those things will bring enough new
energy to still feel to some degree
fresh
between all this stuff and I didn't even
mention that that he's already launching
into spin-offs and planning them already
right off the bat which is another thing
that makes me nervous
every announcement that just is bringing
back
the old people from when he did it
before
I have less and less hope in what
initially had been my big I very
prominent faith that he would do
something new
that faith is gone and the hope is
dwindling
and look I do understand the concerns
about bringing in a whole bunch of brand
new writers there were some issues when
chiminal tried to do that but
there isn't necessarily a reason to
bring in the people who specifically
wrote Under you and specifically wrote
for Doctor Who you can find experienced
writers you can heck bring back some
stuff that wrote some scripts for
Moffett but maybe not for rdt or RTD
sorry I hope I didn't mess that up and
rearrange the letters elsewhere but like
look I'm
this really stresses me out
and again I like Murray gold objectively
I like his music better but I was also
ready to be done with it just so that it
could be one thing that didn't feel like
the old flavor
and it's coming back
I really hope the specials are great
huh
I don't need a repeat
of what happened with the chiminal era
where I came in going I'm excited to see
what's new
and then just get let down over time now
it wouldn't be a total repeat because in
the case of chipmunk there actually was
a fair bit new but it still let me down
for various reasons whereas this it
would let me down by not being new
I'm get I'm getting real nervous I'm
getting real real nervous
and I hope I'm wrong I really hope I'm
wrong I want to be wrong I want these
fears to just get completely
Blown Away put to bed
just go well that was dumb that I was
ever nervous that's how I want to feel
but I can't change the way how I feel
right now which is
oh there's a lot of old stuff
I was gonna try and just uh cut this in
with my old outro that I shot in the
original video I can't remember how I
did that so I don't know how to lead
into it so this is now the outro what
are your thoughts on all this stuff
the costumes Jinx Monsoon Murray gold
any of it all of it
do people think I'm overreacting in my
nerves yeah probably
probably but whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills enables me to do this as my living
and even if you can't help me out with
that like share subscribe are also a big
assistance but what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
nervous or excited you are the council
and I am just running the meeting so
until next time this Council is
adjourned
[Music]
my thanks to all my patrons but in
particular I want to thank Robin Moore
Zubin lotfulla Sarvis to rock the thing
that goes dork in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
ulurik Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks for Nabi likes the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor goddess Elita
Elida not sure ah David Hall Shayla
Gourley Rosalind Bennett you want to
hear me mess up your name too it's in
the patreon perks
I gotta work on that
[Music]
foreign